misery was directed by Rob Reiner right
in the middle of his prime where he was
just making hit after hit after hit it
stars James Caan and Kathy Bates and was
adapted from Stephen King's book misery
Stephen King himself has listed this as
one of his top favorite movies that was
ever adapted from his films and with
good reason this movie is
suspense-filled from the very opening
shot you get this really great close-up
of a cigarette and a match and those two
things are very integral to the
beginning and the end of the film in
this opening we see Paul Sheldon's
played by James Caan who is a very
famous romance novelist he has a very
popular series of books based off of
this character named misery and he also
has a lot of fans some of them are
pretty great and some of them are like
Kathy Bates an obsessed murderer how
unfortunate for Paul Sheldon that after
completing his newest novel he wipes out
on the road and is rescued by Annie
Wilkes his number one fan a nurse
wow that's great not really she's kind
of a psychopath at first you think wow
this is like the sweetest woman on the
planet but her obsession with Paul
Sheldon has grown so deep that she views
his books as almost real and when she
finds out that in the newest misery
novel he decided to kill the lead
character misery she goes insane and
makes his life a living hell she keeps
him trapped she keeps him sick and this
is where Kathy Bates oscar-winning role
really shines because she can go from
the sweetest woman on earth to a
horrific psychopath like that
and a lot of it has to do with some
really excellent writing by William
Goldman who also wrote Rob Reiner zuv
Princess Bride as well as Reiner x'
excellent Hitchcockian level direction
this is a suspenseful movie as I said
from the opening shot just the first
sequence where we're introduced to Paul
pounding away on his typewriter is
suspenseful and a lot of it is the
editing the editing in this film is
pristine the shots are specifically
designed to ring any bit of tension out
of the moment they can his use of
close-ups
Alley's and some truly horrific wives is
masterful rob reiner did a fantastic job
with this movie and like I said this was
in the middle of rhinos Prime he was
pumping movies out like stand by me
another really good Stephen King
adaptation The Princess Bride When Harry
Met Sally misery he went through a great
period of hips and this one might be my
favorite of his the great Richard
Farnsworth plays the local sheriff who
was an amazing actor I missed that guy
every time I see him in a movie and he
embodies his character so well he has
such a funny relationship with his wife
who also is his deputy there's moments
in the car between the two of them where
she touches his leg and he's like hey
nope when you're in this car you're my
deputy ain't my wife the sheriff and the
deputy are integral to the plot because
they're investigating the disappearance
of Paul they're trying to figure out
where he could possibly be but they also
provide a lot of levity in the film
because they're quite funny and it's a
nice breather because sometimes this
movie can just get to 110 percent level
of intensity and suspense and you need
those few moments of comedy and this
movie definitely provides them there's a
fantastic bit where James Caan is just
he's had enough she is at the point
where she is now forcing him to write a
new book in which the character misery
is resurrected he has no choice but to
do this because she's keeping him there
she's drugging him his legs are broke to
shit and he starts pounding away in the
typewriter and we cut to this and you
see that he's typing that and it's just
great let's talk about Kathy Bates I
mentioned she wanted an Oscar for this
movie and she did which interestingly
fun fact this is the only Stephen King
movie to have won an Oscar not Shawshank
not stand by me Kathy Bates and misery
that's pretty impressive and kind of
crazy actually because there's some
pretty damn good Stephen King films out
there she deserves it this is a role
that could easily have gone into B movie
territory if the wrong actress was cast
so they made an excellent choice in
giving Kathy Bates this role this isn't
the only time she's been in a Stephen
King adaptation she was also in Dolores
Claiborne now we're going to get into
some spoilers here if you've never
in misery and I hope that you have
because it's an excellent film and
pretty much anybody who loves movies
should check it out at some point but
we're going to get into the scene that
everyone knows as the hobbling scene
easily the most infamous scene in the
film where Annie Wilkes begun to realize
that Paul's going to be well enough to
walk soon and she decides to make sure
that that's not going to happen she
takes a sledge hammer and a wooden block
and breaks both of his ankles it's
gruesome horrific disturbing and
everything that a horror film fan should
enjoy watching and it's it's great this
movie is so psychologically disturbing
and there's something painfully real
about it even though it's it's kind of
over the top and Annie Wilkes as a
character is super religious she has a
cross she always is saying things like
gee golly wilikers and oh my goodness
and cockadoodie and like she refuses to
curse when she reads Paul Sheldon's new
novel that he's thinking of publishing
she's like this is terrible there's too
many swear words in it and he's like
it's about slum kids I was a slum kid we
all swear and she's like no no I don't
swear and she gets really mad all of a
sudden foreshadowing the insanity
beneath that character and my god I mean
I'm talking a lot about Kathy Bates
because she deserves it this is an
iconic performance but not to be
overlooked is the equally great James
Caan I have a lot of respect for him for
taking this role for one specific reason
alone beyond the fact that he is damn
good in this movie many actors turn it
down including people like Mel Gibson
Robert De Niro Michael Douglas Robert
Redford Morgan Freeman Dustin Hoffman
Harrison Ford Al Pacino and some have
speculated that that's because the
character of Annie Wilkes overshadows
the character of Paul she's so big and
larger-than-life and a lot of actors
didn't want to take that role because
she would be the one everyone noticed
which it's true she got an Oscar win out
of it and James can walk away with
nothing I respect Khan a lot for taking
this part this is a ballsy role you have
to be in bed for almost the entire movie
and we are not in bed you're in a
wheelchair and you had to pull off a
very difficult thing for an actor to do
and that is to act act because in the
film he essentially has to pretend to be
someone else to placate Annie Wilkes his
character he has to pretend that he is
starting to fall in love with her well
in reality he's not he's trying to
figure out every second how we can get
out of the situation that's really hard
for an actor to do because you have to
be yourself the character while also
pretending to be someone else you're
pretending and pretending and James Caan
is so good in the Stone the score by
Marc Shaiman also should not be
overlooked it's highly tense and adds
quite a bit to every single moment as
the film builds to the finale when we're
dollying in on Paul Sheldon holding that
paper he's about to light it on fire and
you see the horror in Annie Wilson face
it is one of the most enthralling
cathartic moments I've seen in a
thriller the following sequence where he
beats her over the head with a
typewriter is also fucking fantastic
because she was forcing him to write a
book that he didn't want to write which
obviously is a very horrible thing to do
as well as the physical torture and
mental torture and he uses that
instrument that she was torturing him
with to beat her over the head it's so
great and that Stephen King he is
amazing at revenge but it's not even the
physical part of their confrontation
that was so satisfying when we're
dollying towards him and we see that
reaction in her face where she realizes
that for the first time in the entire
movie he has the upper hand on her and
she's going to have to do something
about it it's so great you just feel you
just feel the goosebumps all over your
body as you're witnessing this character
finally get what we have wanted him to
have for the whole movie freedom misery
is one of my favorite Stephen King
movies it's one of the best thrillers
ever made and it absolutely deserves an
A+
guys thank you for continuing to watch
my Stephen King series leading up to the
Dark Tower in it I'll be back very soon
with some more Stephen King reviews you
guys are the best and as always if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]